this course consists of four lessons
here in lesson one we'll go over the
basics of monetization strategies and
why it's important for you to think
about monetization from the very start
in lesson two we'll go into detail on
monetization models available for
different types of products feel free to
jump around to the content that is most
relevant to your needs then in lesson
three you'll develop a monetization plan
for the model that you've chosen and
finally in Lesson four
we'll cover best practices for measuring
the performance of your monetization
strategy we'll also talk about when is
the right moment to change your strategy
and optimize it our goal in this course
is to help you plan your monetization
strategy in order to have a sustainable
business sustainable business is all
about making money let's start by
talking about profitability